I want us to just not break up it's my
main goal we're bringing in three
couples we're gonna bring him in they're
gonna sit down the girl's gonna leave
and then the guys in it tell us what he
wants us to turn his girlfriend into I'm
willing to do that no matter how crazy
it is on her face I don't know if she
really wears makeup except like when we
go to weddings no I I know what I'm
talking about though I just you just
said mascara on my face Alison's typical
makeup look is kind of a lot like this I
don't have any makeup on right now but
you don't ever do you you don't get very
much on I think it'll be fine but it
might be a lizard or a bird you know if
you get like a bikini sweating are you
nervous what yeah because there's no way
this kid any well for me so I don't
either way I want us to just not break
up - you have like a vision like what
you think you want on her face I
definitely have a vision perfect we like
a man with a plan so I think we're gonna
ask you to step aside and then we're
gonna have a powwow you trust me okay
Chris so what are you excited to have me
do makeup wise to your girlfriend I was
thing about this the other day I was
watching The Mummy and the girls have
those things going on like this like
Cleopatra yeah that was cool here's the
thing
Alison is very nice skin but she's very
pale so we want to give her a tan
bronzer on yeah
do not make a terminology because I've
used too much I like her skin tone but
maybe a little bit paler norfair yes
make it look like Snow White
okay like when she wakes up though not
when she's like dead yeah ideally what
we do is make the eyes kind of pop with
some liner and blue eyeshadow and give
her like a bright lip I'm thinking like
Scarlett Johansson mixed with Cleopatra
okay I got it
I I think I got it I hope I make you
brown okay you ready yes I'm nervous to
see what he chose for you I am
nervous but again I feel like I'm in
good hands he brought a challenge
[Music]
I got in this lip line yeah I was this
when I tell you that dance from New
Jersey
[Music]
I hope this looks good whoa Wow look at
this I think this would be cool like the
weddings I think I have a good stuff
interesting no no I think honestly I
stand by my eyes I think the lips are a
little Jersey little jerk that's what it
is yeah that's exactly what it is this
is what girls look like where I come
from kind of like a superhero so much
trouble
oh okay it's not as it's it's crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait really you think I did a good job
yeah I was imagining like you know when
there's a bad wax museum that's what I
look like this is it I get to see you
with like a vodka tonic like you get to
the point you know I think this would be
a great look if you
we're going to see family you know a big
family reunion and something like two
minutes I'm kind of used to it now yeah
because you switch girlfriends every 10
minutes I just look like on the next one
so guys pretty much know nothing about
makeup I don't know much about makeup
but I think this is awesome
I think you'd rock this on the regular
you know I'm saying so whether you wear
tons of makeup or not a lot of makeup
your boyfriend or girlfriend should love
and adore you for your heart and your
soul there's so many different versions
of Macy and when you wear makeup this is
a different version than your normal
self I love it just as much as I love
the regular Macy thank you I think I
learned that Steven like even though he
doesn't really know like on a daily
basis shows that he does pay attention
or it does like notice things take away
should be that I think she looks
beautiful no matter what she wears what
it was nice to take away when was that
ever even let's all just remember that
that's bull that's you covering your ass
for me horrible mistake
[Music]